the Fire Nation is embarked on a dark
path and the world might never
[Music]
recover the world needs the
Avatar it needs you
[Music]
and the Fire Nation has destroyed
everything in their
path if the world is going to have any
chance it's going to need
a right there goes the savior of the
world I've chased down every hint of the
Avatar it's my
[Music]
destiny
I'm not someone who can stop the Fire
Nation I don't want the
responsibility you don't have to do this
world you have me Tara and a flying ball
ofer who more do you
need the world needs
you remember what it is we're really
fighting
for the ones
we
love I'm the Avatar and I'm going to
save the
world with my
[Music]
friends ch cheuck cheuck
Chuck